c'est Michael Bryce j'ai un
agent de protection exécutif j'ai extrait mon
client le nettoyage est nécessaire vous voudrez peut
-être appeler l'escouade antibombe ils obtiennent les
pompiers non Michael j'ai peur de
venir s'asseoir un peu plus longtemps
le procès se poursuit l'un des  le
plus brutal du monde ce soir avec un témoin clé
pour témoigner Je peux vous assurer que ma mère
prévoit une foire aux chansons pour cette agression
Kincaid est mort, vous serez payé en totalité
s'ils n'ont pas de propriété J'ai un travail,
voyez le dix pieds est dedans  là
quoi 27 fois
c'est combien de fois ils ont essayé de me tuer
26 28 heureux à l'abri de tous ceux qui
rient tous quelle erreur sans dire où est
votre mari vous avez perdu mon mari avez-
vous une idée à quel point vous êtes stupide de
toute façon Bryson Kincaid sur moi ils tuent
chacun  autre si ça te dérangeait l'arme
[Musique]
non Bob est mort d'
accord pays 1 mon mauvais ton mauvais dieu l'homme a
tué plus de 150 personnes tue 50 facilement je suis
un agent de protection exécutif classé triple A
et tu es le tueur à gages le plus recherché
dans le  monde
mon travail est de k  te garder hors de danger
[Rires]
tu vas durer une heure sans moi à peu près
aussi utile qu'un préservatif chez une
soeur confidentielle pour trouver un moyen plus intelligent
[Musique]
oh bon Dieu j'étais ici
je ne pense pas  tue-le je vais vraiment bien
pays un d'accord tu es mauvais
[Musique]
vraiment ce qui est arrivé à la salle de ceinture de sécurité
toi